at this new store in New York City it's
all about years you ever think you'd
ever talk about years this much I never
thought I would ever talk about years as
much I never thought I would look at
yours this much um I also never really
knew that right selects could be so
different and also family ears could be
so different those differences are what
gave Nikki Kaufman the idea to start a
customized gear phone company called
normal it's completely normal to have an
ear that does not fit regular headphones
or earphones it's normal one size fits
none using her experience with 3d
printers Nikki figured out a way to size
print and ship headphones that fit
perfectly in her customers ears I'll
start with your left ear snap a few
pictures upload them using the normal
app and then choose your color scheme so
now we get to design them or customize
as we call it at normal once you build
your buds they're formed by engineers
molded by 3d printers and sent through
an assembly line for completion normal
earphones are completely different from
anything else on the market we're trying
to kind of tackle sort of three
different things so it's fit it's
customization it's also the sound
quality they're super premium on top of
that normal promises to ship every pair
within 48 hours how scalable is this
business it's actually very scalable
we're not just mentioning headphones so
the potential of mass customization
through 3d printing of other goods is
there and something that we're
potentially thinking up for the future